AGREEMENT AT THIS TIME, WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENGAGING
WITH THE PLAINTIFFS INTO
BRINGING JUSTICE TO THE VICTIMS
OF THIS POLICY.
MIGRANT APPREHENSION IN NOVEMBER
MORE THAN DOUBLING COMPARED TO
2020 WITH OVER 173,000
ENCOUNTERS.
TODD: DESPITE THE FIGURES
DEMOCRATS REFUSE CONSTRUCTION OF
A WALL ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
BRANDON JUDD, NATIONAL BORDER
PATROL COUNCIL PRESIDENT.
WE’VE HAD YOU ON EVERY MONTH
WHEN THESE NUMBERS UP. WE
COMPARE THEM TO 2020 AND IT IS
ALWAYS HIGHER INTO DISASTER BUT
DESPITE THAT IS IT SAFE TO SAY
WE WILL NEVER SEE ANY URGENCY
FROM DEMOCRATS TO STOP THEM FROM
BUILDING THIS WALL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT THEY WILL DO IS CONTINUE TO
PANDER TO THEIR BASE.
THEY WANT TO APPEAR LIKE THEY
ARE TRYING TO ENERGIZE THEIR
BASE TO KEEP THEM ON BOARD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, THEY ARE LYING AND
DEFLECTING.
WHEN THEY LIE THEY ARE TALKING
ROOT CAUSES, AS LONG AS I HAVE
BEEN A BORDER PATROL AGENT, THEY
REFUSE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE WHERE ROOT CAUSES
EXIST AND WHEN THEY DEFLECT THEY
BLAME DONALD TRUMP FOR
EVERYTHING WHEN IN REALITY
DONALD TRUMP GAVE THEM THE MOST
SECURE BORDERS THAT EVER
EXISTED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY TALK
ABOUT IT IS NOTHING BUT
RHETORIC.
THEY PROVIDE NO EVIDENCE WHEN WE
CAN GIVE EVIDENCE AFTER
EVIDENCE.
AND AND 75%.
IT WORKED, THAT THE EVIDENCE YET
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> THE DEA SAYS THE AGENCY HAS
SEIZED 15,000 POUNDS OF FENTANYL
THIS YEAR ALONE.
THAT’S ENOUGH TO KILL EVERY
PERSON IN THE COUNTRY.
HUGELY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU FIX THE PROBLEM?
>> YOU CAN’T FIX IT UNLESS
YOU’RE WILLING TO ADDRESS BORDER
SECURITY AT THE ROOT LEVEL.
IF YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING GOING
ON, THE CARTELS AND THE WAY THE
CARTELS ARE ABLE TO BRING PEOPLE
IN WITH IMPUNITY AND CREATE GAPS
IN THAT, THEY ARE APPREHENDING
THAT FENTANYL.
WE NEED TO GET IT AT THE BORDER,
NOT OUR INNER CITY OR SUBURBS OR
RURAL AREAS.
IF WE DON’T STOP IT AT THE
BORDER IT WILL KILL MORE US
CITIZENS BUT THAT IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN UNTIL WE TAKE POLITICS
OUT OF BORDER SECURITY AND ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT THROUGH THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES.
>> WHY ARE SOCIAL MEDIA APPS
DOING MORE TO CUT DOWN ON THIS?
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE IT IS
FACILITATED ON THE APPS?
ARE THEY IN TROUBLE FOR DOING
THIS?
>> YOU WOULD THINK THAT.
THE DOJ, YOU’VE GOT TO LOOK AT
WHO IS RUNNING EVERYTHING.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE INDEPENDENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT IF THEY
DON’T DO WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WANTS THEM TO DO PEOPLE LOSE
JOBS.
THAT’S WHY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DOESN’T GO AFTER THESE
DIFFERENT APPS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN BED WITH
LARGE TEXT, THEY ARE RUNNING
THESE APPS, MAKING MONEY, THE
LARGE TEXT DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
THE LOWLY UNITED STATES CITIZEN.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE BOTTOM LINE,
HOW MUCH MONEY THEY MAKE AND
THAT’S WHY THE DOJ DID NOT GO
AFTER THE LARGE TECH AND ALL
THESE APPS THAT ARE ABLE TO
ADVERTISE THEIR SERVICES WHICH
ARE ILLEGAL SERVICES AND IT IS
KILLING OUR CHILDREN.
LAURA: OPERATION LONE STAR SENSE
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
THE BORDER TO SECURE IT BECAUSE
IT IS STRETCHED SO THIN AND
THERE ARE TEN CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE ACLU
ASKING THE DOJ TO INVESTIGATE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY SAY IT IS
UNLAWFUL, RACIST AND XENA
PHOBIC, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THIS ASK FROM THE ACLU OF TEXAS
DURING CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS?
>> IT IS SO UPSETTING TO ME
BECAUSE THIS IS NOTHING BUT
POLITICAL THEATER.
I WAS JUST IN YUMA ON MONDAY AND
IN YUMA I SAW SEVERAL GROUPS OF
PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY WHITER THAN I AM.
WHAT TEXAS IS DOING IS GOING
AFTER PEOPLE EQUALLY.
PEOPLE VIOLATING TRESPASSING
LAWS, TRAFFIC LAWS, THEY ARE NOT
ENFORCING IMMIGRATION LAWS, NOR
DO I ADVOCATE THEM ENFORCING
IMMIGRATION LAWS, THEY ARE
ENFORCING THE LAWS OF THEIR
STATE WHICH THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
DO.
BECAUSE THIS IS POLITICAL
THEATER EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS
LAWSUIT IS GOING TO BE THROWN
OUT.
IT’S NOT GOING TO GO ANYWHERE
BUT THE ACLU WANTS TO APPEAR
THEY ARE DOING SOMETHING WHEN IN
REALITY ALL THE ARE DOING IS
PUSHING COURTS AND STALKING
COURTS WITH CASES THEY DON’T
NEED.
TODD: THE TEXAS OPERATION IS
NARROWLY TAILORED UNDER THE LAW.
THEY DO WHAT THEY ARE DOING, NOT
ABRIDGING ON FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
LAW.